we work for the man oh no this isn't
about the father this is about the son
Artemis Fowl
[Applause]
you grown strong son and smarter than I
ever imagined
come take me with you you're all I have
no Artie there's just one very important
thing I have to do
[Music]
authorities launched a worldwide manhunt
for the famous collector he is suspected
to have been behind some of the biggest
robberies ever something of value for us
return it to me or I will destroy
everything yes
[Music]
anyone's supposed to see this yet
[Music]
your father is in a complicated
profession for years he is protected
powerful secrets that have kept mankind
safe from the dangers of another world
it's time to face your destiny
but we are not alone in this mold
stidham's is a talented giant Worf and
I'm Holly short your ally on the other
side
it's real
[Music]
alright save my father save the world
you ready fella we just get ahead on
tunas I'm scared too dad
see
I'm the next criminal mastermind
this is what they call greatness I
didn't bring much on trolls anything
else to do cake for the teeth baby
people good to know
you